let me welcome you to the first session
of understanding anger 2.0 this is a
series that I'm doing as a sort of class
although it's not for credit of course
and it's purely for personal enrichment
and we'll only be meeting about once a
month to discuss all these matters so
um let me tell you a little bit about
the purposes of the class and some of
the history and some of the approaches
to anger and then the schedule for study
and then we'll do some q a and
discussion and stuff like that and then
I do have a few interesting
representative passages to kick the
series off with and so it's 2.0 meaning
that this is a new version of something
I think many of you probably know that I
did a in-person talk series invited in
two thousand 15 at the Kingston Public
Library called understanding anger and
it was kind of similar to this in that
we would
spend each session after the first
looking at some thinkers and texts and
discussing you know what is the stoic
approach to anger or what is the
um
Aristotelian approach to anger what do
we see in you know biblical texts or
what do we see in other things as well
and we're going to be doing something
like that but much faster in scope
because one of the nice things about not
being tied to a physical location in a
library is we can do this as long as we
want we don't have to ask for anybody's
permission we don't have to reserve a
room this is the room right here in zoom
and so
um you know I thought I would put
together a new kind of monthly course
Series going back over some of those
thinkers but going deeper into them so
if we want to spend you know three
months on on Plato we certainly can
we're actually lined up to spend two
months on Plato this time around but we
can come back to it if we want to we can
change things around we can scramble
them up we can go back to texts and
thinkers as many times as we want so
that's you know a lot of freedom and I
got to thinking that I I would do this
again in part because some people who'd
watch those videos they were like oh man
I wish you did this again and I've been
teaching a class here at Marquette which
is where I'm broadcasting from right now
for uh you know I did it last semester
and I'm doing it this semester so you
can say I'm doing this course twice
actually three times because I had two
sections over the course of an academic
year
specifically oriented towards anger I
got assigned this core class called
um
service of faith and promotion of
justice and it's supposed to be like a
problem-oriented class and so everybody
teaches it a little bit differently and
I thought well you know I do a lot of
work on Anger Management and philosophy
of anger why not Orient it around that
and so this leads to some of the
purposes of the the class
anger is not an emotion that most of us
in most settings get much structured or
well thought out education about
typically when you actually get some
sort of training or some sort of
information about anger it'll be because
either you sought it out yourself or
because somebody mandated that you
needed to go to anger management right
so you get in trouble at work or you get
in trouble at school or you know maybe
you get taken to court or something like
that and then they assign you anger
management courses and I'm not knocking
that that's really awesome it's great
that this is a you know possibility for
people
but I think that we would probably all
do a lot better if we had you know more
consistent engagement with thoughtful
discussions about anger and we could
benefit from those and so you know what
I've been discovering really since
before 2000 when I was back in graduate
school and I was myself very much
struggling with anger something I still
do struggle with today
um I found that there were a lot of
really helpful discussions in ancient
philosophy in particular and then as I
went on with it I discovered that the
medievals had a lot of interesting and
useful things to say and so did uh quite
a few early modern thinkers and even all
the way up into I don't know you could
say the um you know the 20th century and
even Beyond I mean there's a lot of
great discussions out there
about anger and they're not just in the
psychological literature they're very
often within what we'd call literature
more broadly so like I'm teaching uh
Mary Shelley's Frankenstein to some
undergraduates starting next week and
that is a book that's chock full of
depictions of anger
um there's a lot of interesting
conflicts that didn't have to happen the
way that they did between the Creator
and the creature and you know we're
gonna go into that maybe down the line
and we'll talk about that
um there's there's all sorts of other
great discussions in philosophy in
religious literature in history and
biography you know later on we're going
to look at Plutarch and Plutarch himself
was a biographer very interested in
moral life so
um we're gonna you know look at those
those sorts of matters and
um
I thought that it would be an
opportunity not just for you but also
for myself to learn more about how we
can properly understand anger and manage
it in our own lives but there's also
some you know pure interest and
enrichment it's kind of fun to read
through these texts and think about them
and and talk about them so that's
basically what we're going to be doing
this session is a little less structured
than the upcoming sessions where I'll
have you know texts for you as already
are posted uh for the very uh second
session some platonic texts that we're
going to look at
um but you know we'll we'll have a lot
of time to kind of wander around in the
topic and one of the things that I I
wanted to bring up is that there isn't
like a single understanding or theory of
anger out there not just in the ancient
literature but even in contemporary
psychology there's a lot of different
theories a lot of different treatments
and one of the things that we're going
to find
is that there's a lot of different
lenses through which we can make sense
out of anger and so I just want to lead
you through a few of those at the start
um some thinkers do more of one than
another
some don't always address all of these
but all of these are things we can say
are important in the literature
so you know there's understanding anger
psychologically we could say it has an
emotion or as they would sometimes call
it a passion right A Feeling a sentiment
that's very important figuring out how
anger Works what its causes are what
role we have in you know contributing to
getting angry or to staying calm all
those sorts of things you could say
those fall within the realm of
psychology but they also fall within the
realm of philosophy of emotion and
literature and lots and lots of other
things as well
and then we have we could call it the
physiology of anger the somatic or
bodily aspects you know the Ancients had
different views about where anger took
place inside of us so you'll you'll see
some of these people talking about liver
or bile right uh the notion of being
melancholic
um comes from the the notion of black
bile produced in the liver we usually
think of a melancholic person as being
sad but in actuality melancholics were
you know very often viewed as like the
people get angry quite easily right and
so
um you know how does anger work
Aristotle will say things like oh it's
you know physiologically blood boiling
and pressure around the heart in part
because Aristotle thoughts thought the
heart did the the actual thinking and
feeling
um so you know we're going to explore
some of these things obviously the
physiology of today
is a good bit different than what um the
Ancients thought but it's kind of cool
to look at what they say about the
somatic aspect of anger like where we
feel it how it takes place and then we
have you know all sorts of insights and
assumptions and practices about anger
management and control you could call
this the Practical side right
um what do we do with our anger if we
want to be less angry are there any
exercises or practices or other things
that we can do and you know some of you
may have uh done quite a bit of this in
in your life right that whole thing of
like just count to ten before you say
something well that's a practice right
so we're going to look at a lot of those
over the course of time
um none there we could there's also what
we could call the ethics of anger is
anger something that is simply bad
that's the way that some people look at
is it something that is you know
actually good uh we ought to have anger
we ought to indulge ourselves in it is
it somewhere in between where you know
anger can be good in certain cases or
bad in other cases how do we tell the
difference between these well the
different thinkers that we're going to
look at quite a few of them do in fact
have
some ethical guidance about how we ought
to evaluate anger and that ties in with
the anger management stuff right and the
psychology stuff we can talk about
application of this to personal
relationships or friendships or our
household our romantic relationships
the workplace perhaps not a lot of
ancient people talk about the workplace
but there's no reason why we can't
extend their insights into the workplace
we can talk about anger as having
political or legal Dimensions you know
when somebody commits a terrible crime
but they do so out of what we look at as
understandable anger we often don't
punish them as much right but if we get
angry at those who we are judging or
punishing maybe we do more of it right
Aristotle already notes this back in the
Nico McCann ethics that one of the ways
that you can get people to like not
judge you as harshly is get them angry
at somebody else first so they they
discharge that anger
um we can also talk about anger in
another dimension
um you know we could call this
theological or religious whatever you
want to uh frame it as the ancient Greek
gods who we're going to be looking at in
some respect during this year well they
get angry at people as a matter of fact
I'm going to bring up Demeter and her
anger a little bit later today but we
can talk about the anger of the Gods
Below in ancient Greece and we can talk
about God providing or the gods
providing guidance to human beings about
anger you know in the Hebrew scriptures
in the Book of Genesis the very first
death is a death that is is a murder
committed out of anger Cain uh kills his
his brother Abel and he doesn't do it
just to be a bad guy or because he's you
know a jerk or something he is angry and
God actually sees it and says to him why
are you angry and why is your face or
countenance Fallen you know and then
gives him some advice so there's this
very interesting Dimension about you
know does God get angry are the gods
themselves
um what do they have to say to us human
beings
and um then there's another dimension
and this is not the only uh
exhaustrative you know list of of
possible approaches or Dimensions but I
do want to say that anger is very often
connected up with ideas about
courage or confidence uh as a feeling
and some people mistake those you know
um they they think that if you're
getting angry that's because you are a
bold courageous person
um and you know so we're gonna we're
gonna unpack that as well you know for
example not this year but later on down
the line I would really love to look at
the song of Roland where we have these
warriors fighting against each other and
contending with each other and getting
angry and it's viewed as part of uh
manliness or courage but we can we can
ask well who is really courageous and
who isn't right whose anger gets them in
trouble in these sorts of matters so um
that said the schedule for study next uh
session in March we're going to start
looking at platonic dialogues we're not
going to be
approaching a very structured theory of
you know anger or you know we might even
say the thing in us that gets angry
until the time after that but we're
going to look at a lot of things that
Plato has his character say about why it
is that people get angry with each other
and and when do they get angry with each
other what are the causes of that and is
there anything that we can actually do
about that so I've you know put some uh
suggestions for readings in there and I
mean you don't have to do the readings
if you don't don't want to so don't feel
under great pressure to have to you know
study and take notes because you know
we're going to cover the stuff in these
sessions but uh if you want to it
certainly wouldn't hurt and then in
April we'll continue our study of Plato
that time we'll be looking at anger in a
more structured way we're going to look
at what he actually has to say in the
Republic particularly book four where
thumos which is one of the things that
we translate is anger is in between the
desires at the bottom and rationality at
the top and it performs a vital role and
some people are more thematic and other
people are more motivated by other
things and we're also going to look at
the phaedrus which also which has a
similar
tripartite division of the soul and the
Timaeus where it actually gets lined up
with bodily Parts this is the rational
part this is the angry thematic part and
then below our our belly and our
genitals that's where the desires reside
right so that'll be the next two months
and then we're going to start going off
into some poetry that precedes Plato
specifically Homer's Iliad lots and lots
of discussion of anger going on there
we're actually going to bring up a
famous line from it in just a bit and
then the month after that in June we're
going to look at Hessian another very
important poet for ancient Greek
literature his theogeny and works and
days
then in uh July and August we will be
returning to philosophy
we're going to look at the first person
that we can say actually theorized about
anger in a systematic way and that is
Aristotle Aristotle by the way Aristotle
is how I got into all of this stuff to
begin with you know it was reading his
uh Nick of McCain ethics and rhetoric
and politics and starting to see the
connections between them and also seeing
that I is a very angry person could use
some of this stuff to help me out so
it's kind of a return home for me we're
going to look at Aristotle's rhetoric
particularly booked two and then we're
going to look at you know his ethics
both the nick of McCann and udamian
ethics uh in the next month and maybe
we'll bring in some other things uh from
from here and there as as well if
they're particularly relevant then we'll
be going back for a while to some Greek
literature and we'll look look at
Ashley's or estea if you've ever you
know read that that's the Agamemnon and
uh you know all going all the way
um to uh the the let's call it the
establishment of the court of justice
and The Taming of the furies in the
humanities right so the lot of really
important and interesting stuff in
Ashley's work and then uh the next month
in October we're going to be looking at
the other two major playwrights and
we're going to look at two plays in
particular that are viewed as really
really Central for uh ancient Greek
literature and anger
um one of these by Sophocles the Ajax
Ajax is a guy who's mad as hell
adidasius and tries to kill him
um we'll talk about what what happened
with that and then sort of a centerpiece
uh euripides Medea Medea is one of those
characters who tells us that she is
motivated by anger and she knows she's
gonna do the wrong thing but she's going
to do it anyway and she comes into
discussion by a lot of
people who take her as sort of a you
know what we call it like a threshold
point for anger
and we'll finish up the Year by looking
at the Epicurean tradition we'll look at
epicurus and lucretius and what they
have to say about anger and then we'll
um delve into stoic philosophy a little
bit by looking at one particular work by
Seneca called on anger
in Latin and as a matter of fact uh I
should point out that so lots and lots
of Greek stuff right and then with
lucretius and Seneca we're getting our
first taste of Latin
um so I'll be referencing a vocabulary
that has to do with anger from time to
time maybe what I'll actually I haven't
thought about this before because I'm
kind of winging this in some respects
maybe part of what I'll do is put
together something almost like a
glossary of terminology that we see
coming up in these different
um thinkers writers bodies of picture
because there is a very rich
vocabulary both in Greek and Latin
having to do with anger and all the
other things it bleeds off into you'll
get a little taste of that in just a bit
but uh let me take a pause and address
any questions or confusions
clarifications
concerns that any of you might have
about what I've said so far is everybody
you know pretty clear about what we're
going to be doing
um you know I I'm I'm actually putting
together a frequently asked questions
file in the class website to address
things and maybe some of the questions
that you might ask right now would go
into that I'll also say too something
that I often say to my academic students
that if you have a question or confusion
odds are you are far from the only
person who is wondering about that thing
so don't be shy if you have anything
that you uh oh a very good question from
Nicola is it okay if we read the text in
different languages absolutely I'm not
going to like require a standard text of
anything and I I will say that so I you
know I work in basically
five languages you know English French
German uh Greek and and Latin ancient
Greek not not demonic Greek
um and you know when I say work in I
mean read right because I my my French
is pretty good my German when I actually
get to German speaking places it takes
me about a week to get back up to speed
as I found out when I was last time I
was in Switzerland
um when you get older it's not quite so
easy to to kick it back in right so yeah
every one of those languages I can say
this that there's a vast and Rich
vocabulary in each of them and they
don't all map on to each other neatly
but uh you can say the same thing about
English translations right so if we take
Aristotle there's a number of
translations of Aristotle's Greek into
English out there and they don't always
line up exactly
saying the same thing because you know
to to translate you have to do some
thinking about what is this person
trying to mean so perfectly fine to read
the texts in different languages and I
think that's a great thing to do while I
wait for anybody else to have any
questions I'll tell you a little story
about when I was a graduate student
more than 20 years ago I spent an entire
semester working with and I'm forgetting
his name was Johnson he was a Classics
Professor he and I read Aristotle's Nick
and McCain ethics in Greek over the
course of a semester and you know being
kind of a go-getter I had an English
translation as well that we'd look at
but then I went to the library and I was
like looking at well what are French
translations of this how do they make
sense out of what Aristotle is saying
and some of them were very literal and
some of them were very periphrastic
meaning that they they'd add other stuff
in to try to help the reader understand
and it was a little bit
um sketchy sometimes the translations
and that's that's really cool you know
so
um all right so Elliot has a great
question here I saw you provided
readings for the next session on
teachable will all the upcoming readings
be available prior to each session yeah
I'm definitely going to be building that
out
um
and I'm doing that not because you know
like I require you to to read them
um I suppose I should call them
suggested readings or something like
that but because
um you know you probably get more out of
it if uh
if you you do that
um and I will be putting them there you
know I'll usually be one of the great
things about working on these older uh
authors
pretty much anything we want to look at
should be available in the public domain
so you shouldn't have to Shell out you
know a lot of money to buy the tax for
this class you should be able to go and
find them online now they may be older
translations sometimes a little bit
oxfordy in the English you know using
terminology we don't always use right
but that's that's okay
um you know I'll speak in
and English vernacular of the 21st
century and hopefully we'll get around
that James says for some reason both my
camera and my mic don't work yeah
because
um I'm I'm gonna be the only person in
these sessions who's on camera and Mike
and we will be using the chat for that
and the reason why I'm doing that is in
is partly because we're recording right
um so this is going to go into a YouTube
video later I I have actually kicked
around the idea of doing like you know
the first part of the session like this
and then changing it uh at the end and
opening it up so we can do something a
little bit more more intimate
um but I also don't want to get like
Zoom bombed or stuff like that I don't I
don't really know everybody here yet and
uh I'd hate for somebody to be like you
know
um as sometimes happened with like heavy
metal sessions or things like that uh
doing things are not supposed to be
doing so now James says The Iliad
probably the first famous work of
literature in the Western World opens
with the word anger in some way you
could say Western culture begins with
anger as any particular reason you start
with Plato and go back to the Iliad
instead of going chronologically
uh yeah I mean we're going to talk about
The Iliad in that verse today so
um and weirdly it's it's a term for
anger that often isn't used in other
texts and the reason we're going to
Plato is because I wanted to have
something a little bit more
systematic less like all over the map
and episodic for our beginning you know
the sessions so
all right James uh says will you tell us
which translations editions you
primarily will be working from to
prepare present each month uh no not
exactly I mean I can tell you this that
typically if I've got it in the lobe
Edition which is English and and Greek
or Latin on facing Pages I'm using that
but
um I I don't I don't you know have like
preferred translations
um I actually have a whole video out
there of uh sort of like a frequently
asked questions which which is the best
translation of this
I don't know because being able to read
things in the original I'm kind of lazy
that way
um so you know uh you know I will have
suggested like online translations that
you can use and actually I should
probably consider hunting down some in
other languages too that might be kind
of nice
um James also says uh I'm very excited
about getting around to stoicism so I'll
need to be patient well uh yes and no I
mean I do have quite a few videos out
there about stoicism and anger that you
could take a look at if you want to
um and some writings as well on on
medium but yeah the the class session
specifically about stoicism well a stoic
Seneca right who doesn't always agree
with Epictetus uh or Marcus Aurelius on
some of these matters
um yeah we'll be doing that in in
December but we'll also be coming back
in the year after that I I should
actually mention this so this is
intended to go on for years and years
and years if there's sufficient interest
in it I'm interested in the topics and
I'm hoping you know that all of you
retain your interest in the topics
although I mean if you're getting into
this in part because you're an angry
person and you know it's mainly about
anger management and then you become
less angry that would actually be a a
you know a positive wouldn't it so
um but I'm gonna I'm intending to like
do this for for quite a long time and um
if you happen to miss sessions you can
always come back to them later on so
all right well let me move on to the
other part that I had planned for today
today will probably be a little bit of a
shorter session than the others I'm
anticipating them running about
you know anywhere between an hour to 90
minutes and most likely on the longer
end in in the future because there's a
lot for us to cover but
I um picked out a bunch of
representative passages and so you know
the very first one James uh brought up
uh is the beginning of the Iliad right
and
um here's here's a just a English
translation of it I'm not sure who it's
by because I I just picked it out kind
of at random and we'll talk about that
the Greek vocabulary in a bit the Wrath
sing goddess of peleus's son Achilles
that destructive wrath which brought
countless woes on the acadians and sent
forth to Hades many Valiant Souls of
Heroes and made themselves spoiled for
dogs and every bird thus the plan of
Zeus came to fulfillment from the time
when they first parted in Strife
atrius's son king of men and Brilliant
Achilles who then are the gods was it
that brought these two together to
contend the son of Lido and Zeus for he
in Anger against the king roused
throughout the host an evil pestilence
and the people began to perish because
upon the priest chrisus the son of
Atrius had wrought dishonor right it's a
quite a start you know if you if you
wanted to start out a book or a story or
even podcast with with a real bang uh
Homer
he's he's a master at that isn't it and
you know like James is saying the very
first word is Menace which uh in Greek
is is kind of an unusual term it's
actually Menin because uh you're it's in
the accusative
you know uh goddess uh speak or sing uh
uh this this rage this wrath that is in
there and then we notice some other
um anger terminology and Homer uses you
could say
um older more archaic words right a lot
of the words that we're going to be
looking at later on are thumos or Oregon
or
um Hala pinene or things like that
um this Menace is is a unusual term and
then
um when we get to this uh parting in
Strife
eresante right Ires is Strife in in
Greek a word that we're going to look at
in a few other authors and strife is
contending against each other they also
use the term
uh to fight against each other which
becomes a technical term in Greek
Philosophy for not just conflict but
contradiction you know like when you
have your your own self-contradictions
um in this it's they're actually
contending with each other and why are
they doing this well it's because
um Achilles is pissed off with Agamemnon
the you know atreus's son king of man
right who's being talked about there and
uh the the being angry in this case uh
Holo face so it's coming from holos
which means
um you know literally your bile in your
liver right they thought that anger was
seated in the liver and like went
throughout the whole body and gets you
all dark and riled up and stuff like
that right so remember we were talking
about this somatic
um dimension of of anger so that's in
the very first paragraph of The Iliad
and we'll we'll see when we turn to
Homer later on that there's a lot of
discussion in there particularly when uh
Odysseus and Nestor and a few of the
others go to talk to Achilles and
they're like hey buddy um why so angry
can we talk is there any way we can like
work this out and get through this we
also have this really interesting uh
description really on where Achilles is
deliberating should I kill this bastard
right here where he stands the leader of
the entire host Achilles if he wants to
kill somebody he can do it right
and he doesn't do it he Masters his own
anger at least enough to not destroy the
uh the unity of the um the Greek um
War host so that's a really important
one another one I thought would be kind
of cool to take a look at is two
passages from heraclitus heraclitus who
by the way didn't like Homer very much
actually Eric clitus doesn't like a lot
of people very much right if you read
through his his fragments and heraclitus
uh there's two passages in particular
um he says we must know war is common to
all and strife is Justice and that all
things come into being and pass away
through Strife this is something that
gets taken up by other philosophers as
really characteristic of heraclitus
including uh Plato in the Symposium so
War polymone right fighting uh
contending with each other is common
sunon in his his uh ionian Greek and
then Eris again uh Strife is Justice DK
right the the Reckoning you could say
and then he goes on and says uh all
things come into being ignomina and uh
you know
um pass away through Strife
literally not necessarily through but in
accordance with that and then he has a
passage that has been quoted by so many
people including many in the ancient
times
it is harder to fight against pleasure
than against anger whatever it wishes to
get it purchases at the cost of Seoul uh
literally it's it's saying there
um to fight
again we see that term uh is against
anger is very difficult whatever thumos
happens to be in this case and then
there's there's some
interesting controversies Aristotle
quotes this right and so do other
ancient philosophers and some
classicists want to say I don't know if
thumos is really anger it might be your
heart's desire it might be just this
part of yourself that we have that
strives after honor so there's a lot of
uh discussions about that by the time
that we've got Plato and Aristotle on
the scene they do think that it refers
to to anger
another great passage actually two
passages come from sappho the poet um
and she she talks uh in her very first
uh verses about shimmering thrown
Immortal Aphrodite uh poiki lothron
which is kind of cool poikilos means uh
multi-colored or shimmering or
iridescent
um and then she at the very end of this
says spare me o Queen this Agony and
anguish right she is in agony and
anguish about things and she says Crush
not my spirit and what is that Spirit
she's talking about there thumos right
is is what it is in the Greek and then
another that comes up which may or may
not be by sappho it's attributed to her
by Plutarch runs like this when anger
spreads through the breast keep thy
tongue from barking foolishly
right
um now uh stay theston is the the breast
the chest right
um and the anger that's being mentioned
there the term is actually orgas
right
um
and so that is a you know later term
that we see a lot like in Aristotle or
Plutarch or these other people
um and so you know she's saying when
this is like taking you over then uh you
need to like restrain that tongue of
yours because otherwise you're going to
say
dumb stuff and I mean is this kind of a
cultural
um what would we call it constant you
know that people get angry and then they
say things they maybe don't mean or they
do mean they shouldn't say at the time
uh yes
um
then we have this hymn that I mentioned
a little bit earlier the him to Demeter
the homeric hymn to Demeter the goddess
of uh you know agriculture
um foilage fruits grain all of these
sorts of things and this is a recounting
when a terrible thing was done to
Demeter's daughter Persephone and
Demeter herself uh went into uh both a
depression but also a rage about it
Hades if you know the story sees
Persephone and thinks that she's really
beautiful and lovely and decides to take
her down to Hades or Hell the Unseen
realm opens up a Chasm grabs her takes
her down has sex with her I mean the
ancient some of the stories that we get
you know is
she was just down there being Queen you
know in a few pomegranate seeds yes but
he also had sex with her and Demeter
sees her her you know daughter who she
loves
um and can't find her afterwards akate
comes and remonstrates with her and then
Helios does as well and Helios says to
her
I urge you God to stop your loud Cry of
lamentation Megan
uh then he says you should not have an
anger without bounds and what is the
term that he's actually using there hold
on again that liver you know bile kind
of thing right
yeah he says
you should not have a wrath that is
unbounded and then he he actually says
you know it's not too bad being uh um
you know the wife of of Hades you know
he's he's great son-in-law he's the
brother of Zeus shouldn't you be happy
about this right and then uh he takes
off and we find out that this does not
work at all all his his argument is
rejected and we see and she Demeter was
visited by grief ajos that was even more
terrible than before and where is this
grief happening in her thumon in her
thumos and then we have another term
that gets used
um
uh in her anger at the one who's known
for his dark clouds the son of Kronos
she shunned the company of the Gods and
lofty Olympus she visits the human
beings and the Greek word that's being
used there's a verb
um HOSA mene right and so this is
another one of those you know getting
riled up getting angry being Grudge
holding
um she withholds her uh Power to make
things grow it's bad for everybody and
so we see this interesting connection
between grief and pain and anger coming
up even among the gods right
um the last thing that I was going to
share with you
has to do with another one of the like
we could call it the Hallmarks for Greek
ancient Greek culture
and that's the delphic maxims you know
we we all know know yourself right and
nothing too much but there were a whole
bunch of other uh maxims that were
important carved into uh places at
Delphi and that the ancient Greeks
thought communicated some wisdom and
among these is one number 16 fumu karate
control your anger control your desire
for Revenge control the part of you that
gets riled up and is you know concerned
with honor and that that sort of thing
um but there's a number of other ones
that kind of fit in with this
so some of them have to do with the
things that produce anger right number
80 Erin mise despise Strife actually a
little bit more literally translated
hate Strife why because Strife produces
anger right it gets people uh to fight
against each other uh 82 glochon is
restrain the tongue keep keep some you
know power over that
um number 83 Who brain uh Moon Muno keep
yourself from hubris from insolence from
insulting other people from doing things
that as the ancient Greeks recognize are
causes of anger and then finally uh
number 84.
make just judgments when you judge judge
what is actually just and don't play
favorites don't don't do things that
tend to tick people off so
um you know it's giving you not in a
very systematic way but it's giving you
some of the keys for like how not to get
other people angry or allow yourself to
get angry
and then uh some of the later maxims
there's there's a set that have to do
with uh hatred
okay
or amnesty and they use two different
terms again
do away with undo literally uh enmities
hatred between you and other people who
might be your Rivals uh Fairway
again same sort of uh root there the the
actros flea amnity or you could say
reject enmity and then finally uh number
119 kakian mise again we see this hatred
word right misos is hatred kakia is is
bad stuff uh wickedness is another way
of translating it just try to despise
that hate that sort of thing now if you
do that you might actually get angry at
people doing what you take to be evil or
or wrong as well
so these are some interesting starting
points that I just wanted to throw in
front of you sort of like a moose
or sometimes we call them appetizers you
know some really tiny appetizers before
the the main course which will happen
next month with with Plato you know
we'll have two courses of him over the
next couple uh months
uh and we will come back to Homer of
course but um I thought this might be an
interesting set of starting points to to
begin with so I've been talking at you a
while I'm sure you have some questions
or comments that you want to make and
I'm happy to uh respond to them
um and uh you know we can certainly chat
a bit if it if you'd like about any of
the ideas that this provokes for you
so let me while I'm waiting for you to
write I'll take a little drink here
I should I should mention too that uh
I personally
you know take kind of an Eclectic
approach to these matters
I'm not you know I think the stoics have
a lot to contribute but I'm I don't buy
their anger is always bad line
completely I'm not on the Aristotelian
side completely either I think the
platonists have a lot to contribute I
think there's a lot of wisdom in some of
the stories that we're going to be
looking at including the Iliad but also
those those tragedies as well you know
the playwrights aren't
um
you know philosophers as such although
apparently euripides and Socrates were
pretty close to each other from from all
accounts all right James says maybe you
mentioned it somewhere but uh how did
you learn to read ancient Greek
so it was when I was in graduate school
um you know by the time that I started
learning it I had you know I I was
really advantaged when it came to French
in a way because my my mother's family
is francophone and so you know I learned
kind of a half-assed French and then
learned some more in college and then uh
German I'd had a bit of and you know
went through a teacher self German
course and uh took a little bit of uh
courses on that and then Latin I also
worked through on my own although I I
was fortunate in that I had you know
kind of a foundation of it back in
middle school so Greek was a different
matter and they offered classes in
classical Greek
um where I went to graduate school at
Southern Illinois University in the
classics department and I you know I
wanted to be able to read Plato and
Aristotle and other philosophers in the
original
um and so I signed up for the you know
um first class and we we started out
with 12 students we finished with only
four
and then we started the next semester
with those four and we finished with two
because it was a pretty intense course
right and it was Rick Williams who was
the head of the honors program teaching
that he was an old guy and and kind of
cool you know very theatrical and then
after that you you started reading
authors and so I took you know the next
class which was a readings class and we
read Lucian and some Plato and
somebody else Licious
um and then I took a Herodotus course
and now we're learning you know a
different uh dialect right uh we're
looking at ionian and then after that I
started doing like independent studies
on uh played I did Plato Symposium with
Rick Williams and Aristotle's Nick and
McCain ethics and then after that I just
started reading and I I want to say this
too every author you kind of have you
don't start from the very beginning but
you're learning a new vocabulary with
each author that you read so like
Epictetus is Greek there's a lot of
words in there that you're not going to
find
in Aristotle or in Plato or in in others
as well and um you know people who say
oh coin a it's kind of baby Greek no not
the case at all in Epictetus
um and so you just kind of like work at
it and it's very helpful to have a Greek
grammar the Smythe that you can consult
from time to time so that that helps as
well
um
all right Bruce says would you say that
anger is a state of affairs or situated
um I mean it
you can be angry at a state of affairs
and I suppose your anger can be part of
a state of affairs right but it is also
you know you could call it situated or
grounded it's it's something that we
feel within ourselves and not just in
like one way right I mean it affects our
body it affects our psyche or our mind
it colors our perceptions of situations
as Aristotle recognizes in in the
rhetoric book too the angry person sees
the world in a different way Heidegger
himself picks up on this calling you
know Aristotle's rhetoric book two a
hermeneutic of every danus
and thinks that you know mood or
Attunement does also affect the way in
which we see things he doesn't talk an
awful lot about anger but
um yeah so that's that's that's
important Nicholas says I had three
semesters of koine Greek but I decided
learning modern Greek that's what I'm
going to do starting April and then I'll
go back to classical Greek yeah and you
know it's funny I so I got two things to
say about that one is that
um classical Greek and and you know
modern demonic Greek are not the same
thing they share some things in common
but I mean it it's sort of like
um saying that you're gonna like you
know you're you know uh contemporary
German so you're gonna go and read the
niba lung and Lead no that's you know
Middle High German right so so uh uh and
and very often demonic Greek speakers
will get kind of snippy about like I
actually had one just the other day who
was trying to correct my pronunciation
of something in
Plutarch maybe and he was like telling
me that the Ada is is pronounced a
different way and it is pronounced a
different way in contemporary Greek
right but it wasn't pronounced that way
back in ancient times as far as we know
you know and sometimes anyway sometimes
they'll be like extra words added in I
remember going to the library in
Fayetteville North Carolina which had
this wonderful foreign language section
and I'm pulling down a book of of Plato
and starting to read through some of the
tetralogies and being like
I've read this before where the hell are
all these extra words coming from well
it was a you could call it contemporary
Greek
redoing of classical Greek you know so
you got to kind of watch that a bit you
know yeah okay so the very good comment
here too from Nicola Italians do the
same with Latin I actually saw a Twitter
Tiff just the other day where
um somebody was arguing that ecclesial
Latin is like the only way to go and
classical Latin is all made up and you
know people get really worked of this
this sort of thing uh I'm not quite when
they get angry right I'm not exactly
sure why I suppose I could dig into it
and like reconstruct why they get so
angry and worked up about it but I just
don't know
why that happens to be the case
I just know that it it does happen
um any other questions or comments or
anything like that
okay so here's a here's a couple good
ones
um Gary says is it helpful to look into
the different definitions of anger
yeah it certainly can be and we will be
looking when there are definitions
rather than you know characterizations
or things like that where somebody says
I Define anger as we'll we'll be looking
at those Aristotle has probably the most
complex definition in rhetoric book two
weirdly enough in the literature when
Aristotle gets brought up
why other ancient authors they don't
usually reference that one they
reference the one that I want to say is
in it's in the topics and I want to say
it's in topics book four
either three or four uh where it's
defined as like a desire to
um make somebody suffer in return to
retaliate right but Aristotle is a very
complex definition that we're we're
definitely going to talk about
um there's some like you know
contentions about like who's got it to
find right when we get to seneca's
um on anger he is going to consider a
number of definitions and say why he
thinks like this one's right this one's
wrong
um lockedancius who I've just been doing
videos on for my Marquette class
um discusses definitions of anger so it
is quite quite useful to
um to try to do that but you don't
always have to have a definition as such
um I'm not a big believer in defining
everything from the beginning and then
operating that way I think like
oftentimes we kind of put things
together
um in a much more
let's see what they say here let's see
what they say here kind of kind of
comprehensive way Nicholas says I'm
Italian so I I know how it is they only
teach the classical pronunciation at
University that's why most people are
unaware of it and that's the way they
find it weird yeah that's quite true
June says
is the translation of classical text
considered the same as interpreting the
text by different people
um
I mean I guess so a translation you're
going from one language to the other
right and you inevitably
as you're translating and this is why
like Google translate
doesn't always get us what we want right
even though it's gotten quite a bit
better over time you as a person trying
to like convey the thought from one
language into another you do have to do
some interpretation
and that's you know sometimes it's off
base depending on what our assumptions
are or biases are and sometimes it it's
brilliant and it takes what's in one
language and it gives it like voice
in another you know
um
so there is interpretation involved in
translation
um
you could also be working from other
people's translations
and interpret what you've what you've
got in front of you with those right so
not all interpretation is translation
and then you could be interpreting
something in its original language too
like when we interpret Shakespeare in
English
um
you know we're not like trans I mean we
are kind of translating his stuff from
an older version of English the same
thing like when we're reading John Locke
or even like David Hume and We're
translating it into a new idiom or
dialect
um but we're not translating it into a
different language right
um so yeah
Nicholas says on another note have you
read many classical texts are you aware
of Scholars who wrote academic books
articles about the history of
hermeneutics interpretations of texts
throughout history
um I mean yeah I've read quite a few
classical texts I guess you can say
um you know I haven't read a ton of them
in the original in part because that
takes a good bit longer
um I mean there's some that I will read
for pleasure in the original like I like
reading Aristotle and Epictetus and I do
enjoy reading Cicero for the style but
um quite often I'm like you know reading
the English and then then like well I
wonder what what's actually here in the
Latin I better go back to that and check
that that's that's typically what I'm
doing and and um
yeah there's a lot of Scholars who've
written about the history of
interpretation of texts going all the
way back into Antiquity I mean
you could think about
um Plutarch as somebody who's like
interested in how do people interpret
the the things that that we've got in
text diogenes liertes lists a whole
bunch of texts nobody takes him
seriously as a brilliant philosopher
because he's not but that's actually why
we like him because we think he's not
making stuff up too much you know
um and you know there's there's all
sorts of it depends on the text right
you can talk about like the um history
of Plato's Symposium
and different interpretations of it
throughout history you know like the
rediscovery of it in the west and during
the Renaissance and then you know like
commentaries on it and you know
reinterpretations into the the late
Modern Age of what's happening there
sometimes taking some some of the parts
this will be kind of a funny note to
some of you there's quite a few dirty
passages dirty from the you know modern
quasi-victorian and quasi-puritan sense
in a lot of ancient literature and when
you when you find older translations
they will often take you know like it'll
be translated in English for all of
these parts and then when they get to
something that has to do with sex
they'll put it in Latin because they
figure that the the school boys uh
probably weren't good enough or you know
enterprising enough to to read the Latin
translation or Latin original of it like
if we're talking about John Cassian uh
and I think that they very much
underrated school boys interest in
Reading what was considered forbidden or
dirty stuff right because if I was you
know some turn of the century British
boy in school you know hearing all these
repressive messages and I knew that
there was some passage in somebody's
text that might be juicy I sure as hell
would learn the land to be able to read
it myself
um so yeah there's there's a
there's a good bit of that going on
um
all right any other questions comments
uh concerns anything like that or I mean
what I think we'll probably do is uh
bring this to a close and then